hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the high resolution
solution accurate mass for the clinical
research laboratory presented by Natalie
Rasmussen we're excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this webinar is sponsored by Agilent
technology agilent is a leader in life
sciences diagnostics and applied
chemical markets the company provides
laboratories worldwide with instruments
services consumables applications and
expertise enabling customers to gain the
insights they seek agilent's expertise
and trusted collaboration give them the
highest confidence in our solution for
more information please go to ww a glint
calm i'm kristina jewel of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge that window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button the let us know that you're
having a problem this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credit after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce Natalie Rasmussen
nellie grew up in salt lake city utah
area and earned a BS in biology from the
University of Utah in 2004 she began
working in the toxicology area at a RUP
laboratories in 2005 where she prepared
samples and analyzed them via immuno a
state and mass spectrometry Natalie
accepted a position as research and
development specialist at AR UPS
Institute for clinical and experimental
pathology in 2012 where she primarily
works on time-of-flight mass spec based
testing she also has some experience
with immunoassay and maldita in her free
time she enjoys exploring the playground
that is utah by hiking and camping she
also enjoys reading cooking playing
softball and attending sporting events
especially at the University of Utah
please join me in welcoming Natalie
Rasmussen i will now please turn the
presentation over to her thank you for
that introduction and hello everybody
the title of my talk is the high
resolution solution accurate mass for
the clinical research laboratory so some
learning objectives for today hopefully
by the end of my talk you will be able
to describe how time-of-flight mass
spectrometry works compare and contrast
tov ms with lcn SMS and begin to assess
what you will need in order to integrate
tov ms into your laboratory here's a
brief outline of my talk first we will
discuss what accurate mass is and what
mass resolution is we'll talk a little
bit about time-of-flight mass spec
anatomy I'll talk about method
development some interesting results in
data mining the strengths and weaknesses
of the instrument some future directions
and then I will open it up for questions
let's start off with a little chemistry
review individual atoms are too small to
put on a scale and weigh so mass is
based on the carbon-12 scale at the
atomic masses of all of the elements are
based on how heavy they are relative to
carbon-12 which weighs exactly 12 AMU
the mass listed on the periodic table up
upper right hand corner of this example
is the average atomic mass it is a
weighted average of the element and its
isotopes in high resolution mass
spectrometry we use exact mass not the
average mass when calculating the weight
of an analyte because the instrument is
capable of detecting all of the isotopes
individually the big number in the upper
left-hand corner is the atomic number
which corresponds with the number of
protons in the atom exact mess like we
just talked about in a previous slide is
calculated based on chemical formula
accurate mass is what the instrument
measures and then the atomic mass is
determined for each element relative to
carbon with the exact mass of 12 there
are two types of resolution when it
comes to mass spectrometry
chromatographic resolution and mass
resolution we will focus on the latter
one today mass resolution is the ability
to distinguish two ions a slightly
different mass over charge in a mass
spectrum the narrower the peak the
higher the resolution the higher the
resolution the higher the mass accuracy
which means the better ability for the
instrument to be able to separate two
compounds very close and mass so the
formula is resolution equals mass over
the Delta M which is a full full with
full width half mass or an older
definition is mass over is the average
of the two masses over the nasty
separation so the same conclusion can be
reached our so a bigger our means a
smaller mass difference can be resolved
so what does that mean
so a triple quad or a single quad is a
nominal mass instrument and a topper
cute off is an accurate mass instrument
on a nominal mass instrument like a
triple quad the peaks of the two
analytes aren't very sharp and there's a
very little baseline resolution the
analytes look like there are about six
14 ish and 6 15 ish but on a high
resolution instrument the peaks are very
clearly separated and the mass is
measured out to thousands of a Dalton
when the resolution equation is applied
the triple quad has a release resolution
of about 90 3 and the top or the Q toss
has a resolution of over 14,000 the peak
is much sharper on a high resolution
instrument and you can see the big space
in between in the top example versus the
triple quad example let me give you a
brief overview of what's going on inside
the instrument the LC stream enters the
source d salvation occurs in ions are
sucked through the capillary they go
through and octupole in a series of
lenses and a quadrupole if you have a
cute off ions will flow through the
collision cell ions are fragmented and
the beam of fragments or intact ions if
you are using a tough instrument or
running the top or the cute ah cintas
mode our further compressed and shaped
before passing into the flight tube
portion of the instrument the pollster
assembly is a stack of flights with a
hole in the middle the bottom plate
called the pusher since ions up through
the plates and toward the top of the
flight tube with an electrical pulse the
reflect reflect Ron or ion mirror sends
the ions back down toward the detector
so how is all of this resolution
achieved physics but only the algebra
based conscience thankfully all charged
ions Z have a potential energy
proportional to the acceleration voltage
when the ion beam enters the poster
assembly of the flight tube because
potential energy is converted into
kinetic energy the first law of
thermodynamics States the energy has to
be convert conserved so potential energy
equals kinetic energy velocity
is the distance or the length of the
flight path / time so the time from the
Pulsar to the detector so from all the
stuff we haven't thought about since our
second year of college we can derive the
main top equation the time of flight
equals a constant times the square root
of the mass overcharge or simply put the
heavier the eye on the longer the flight
time the instrument is calibrated with a
range of masses and the unknowns being
analyzed are compared to this
calibration curve based on their time of
flight the math can be determined
shifting gears a little bit now that
everyone is familiar with how the top
works let's talk a little bit about
method development it's pretty easy for
the most part when I'm developing a new
method I start by creating a database of
the analytes that I'm interested in the
chromatographic part of the method of
development is much like it is on a
single quad or a triple quad instrument
after I figure out what columns and
mobile phases I want to try I prepare a
solution of the analytes I'm looking for
things get a little bit different when
it comes to injecting the standard
solution however I typically prepare a
solution containing all of the analytes
and also to solutions separating any
isobaric compounds since the top is
basing identification and exact mass
only and not fragments we have to rely
on retention time to correctly identify
any isobaric pairs having them in
separate solutions allows you to figure
out which what time each one alludes and
then I try to answer the following
questions when i'm reviewing data did i
find everything well hopefully I did if
I miss something there's ways to dig
deeper and figure out why I like looking
at the extracted ion chromatogram
usually if something is missed it's
because two analytes are interfering
with one another or an isobaric pairs co
eluting i ask myself what is co eluding
and does it matter in my experience
generally compounds can co Aleut as long
as they are far enough apart in mass to
not interfere with one in others
isotopes which is far as identification
algorithm or one isn't going to
completely
ask another because it's going to be
highly concentrated in a biological
matrix like urine Ric Barrett cares
fully resolved there are not in this
example but if they're worth it would
need to be at least based on results and
preferably have a little space in
between them so when your best director
attitude that's after my chart is all
about this was probably the face you
give them but actually it's really easy
to add a compound after your msgs
developed you add the analyte to your
database inject a standard to see to get
the retention time and then add it to
your stock solution to make sure it
plays nicely with everything else isn't
life nice when you don't have to
optimize or D optimize individual
compounds or loop or transitions once
you have your LC method mostly dialed in
you can start playing with the mass spec
parameters to get the best signal some
parameters will depend on the flow rate
of your method like gas temperature to
nebulizer pressure and acquisition rate
if your chromatography is really fast
the instrument needs to scan faster in
order to ensure that it finds all enough
point across the peak the higher the fan
speed though the lower the sensitivity
there sleepin aids we found which is can
be ultra lessons until Kamal feels like
amphetamines will fragment in the source
if you hit it with something too hard
but a compound like tht glucuronic needs
a little extra kick so we can apply a
nozzle voltage different time segments
can have different properties which is
useful for methods that have a lot of
analytes you can also apply a divert
valve at different time segments and you
can even switch polarity at different
time segments as well
but as we know nothing is ever as simple
as it seems if we could only live in a
world where we looked only looked at
standard solutions we've learned a few
things along the way in our top turning
here a RUP what other comment let's see
what other common things in your method
or isobaric with compounds that you're
looking for death in the fac scene is an
active metabolite of venlafaxine and SSN
RI called effexor and it's also
prescribed alone as pristiq years ago
not too long after we got our first top
we started seeing tramadol with a slight
retention time shift and no metabolites
and this is unusual in urine after a
little investigative googling and
looking at the forensic toxicology
database from agilent we discovered that
this could be decimal faxing interfering
so we went and mind the data and look
for the parent drug venlafaxine and then
ordered standards to verify the
retention times of the interfering drug
and its parent we were looking at
marijuana metabolites in umbilical cord
and meconium for a research project when
one of our scientists discovered that
progesterone and cannabidiol or isobaric
they eluded far enough apart not to
cause any problems luckily compounds
that Co elude enter 1 to 2 a.m. use
apart will likely have isotopic
interferences since isotope ratio and
pattern are part of the identification
algorithm they really need to be
separated if possible this includes
internal standards as well so we try not
to use the d3 unless we don't have any
other option so the toff sees everything
since you're collecting full scan data
it's it's going to pick up everything
you put into it so here are a few pearls
of wisdom being clean and testing
everything before you put it into uses
paramount and will save you the
heartache and pain that comes with
troubleshooting do not use parafilm ever
it's the saran wrap of the laboratory
and we love it but the toss does not it
will show up in your samples it'll show
up in your instrument and it's a mess to
sort out only use non
iching plastics if you must use plastic
at all some types of gloves can even
cause problems the highest quality
solvents needed to be used on board the
instrument we use Optima grade methanol
in acetonitrile and Milla Q water in our
laboratory we've tested the lower grade
stuff and it just causes problems hand
wash your dishes detergents will show up
in this signal just like parafilm will
we found that it's best to keep separate
a separate set of glassware for top
related preparation just rinse it with
some IPA and methanol to keep it clean
if it's really dirty a light acid wash
followed by a thorough rinsing with IPA
and methanol will clean things back up
again anytime you get a new lot anything
that touches your specimen or the
instrument tested to make sure that it
performs like the previous lot and
doesn't have any interferences I know
this is standard practice but it's
especially important to remember for an
instrument that sees just about
everything you put in it after all of
this you will still have interferences
you can't explain from time to time
biological matrices are complex and
people have all sorts of diseases and
take all sorts of medications that could
cause something to show up that you
didn't anticipate if you start off with
a good clean sample prep and instrument
practices there's less of a chance of
something getting weird and causing
problems this is an example of
polyethylene glycol contamination see
the fin pattern this is characteristic
of any sort of plastic contamination peg
is 44 a and yo part so it's usually
pretty easy to diagnose and when we see
this we typically have to flush our
Elsie's out and clean everything really
thoroughly and it seems to clear the
problem up
instrument itself is pretty easy to
maintain from day to day you do the
normal LC stuff like checking the
solvent levels and priming the pumps
wipe the inside of the spray chamber
down with a mixture of IPA and water and
then just do a mass calibration for the
instrument all in all it takes less than
15 minutes major service like a
front-end cleaning will depend on what
and how much you're running we are a
busy lab thousands of samples per month
pass through these instruments what we
found is that in every instrument has
its own personality of sorts some can go
longer than others without being cleaned
it usually takes three to seven days for
an instrument to come back to normal
post cleaning the key is paying
attention to changes in your system and
being proactive having a set set of
criteria when you're is have a set of
criteria for when your instrument needs
service area counts are the biggest
indicator We are fortunate because we
have a factory trained service group of
engineers in house because we have over
100 aspects of all shapes and sizes and
brands in the building that they are
capable of fixing and maintaining so
when one goes down help is not far away
but like I said before the key is paying
attention to changes in the system and
acting on them before things become a
crisis that criteria that meet your
needs and get help before it blows up in
your face since we're collecting full
scan data the instrument generates a ton
of data so files can be greater than 1
gigabyte per sample data storage is a
big issue we max out hard drives in
about 40 days once a hard drive is full
the instrument won't run so you'll need
to have a data storage strategy in place
specifically if you're a CLIA lab since
some sort of archiving is required we
archive PDFs of reports and the actual
mass spec data is deleted after a set
period of time you'll have to figure out
what works best for you but keep in mind
that a two terabyte hard drive is going
to fill up faster than you think
now I want to talk to you about some of
the ways in which we use Thomas light in
our laboratories this is a method used
for testing for drugs commonly
prescribed in pain management programs
these drugs are prone to misuse or
diversion so doctors want to make sure
that people people are taking what
they've been prescribed and aren't
enhancing their prescription to her pee
with anything else this is 35 drugs and
metabolites and seven internal standards
in about three and a half minutes I
presented this particular method on a
poster it's often Atlanta Georgia last
year this method is run on our agilent
1260 hplc coupled to an agilent 6230
time-of-flight mass spectrometer
chromatographic separation is achieved
on a phenomena kinetics f5 column heated
to 40 degrees and the mobile phases are
five millimolar ammonium formate ph 3.5
an Optima grade methanol the flow rate
is one mil per minute the method uses an
ESI source with a scan speed of two
spectra per second the gradient is
pretty simple and the whole thing is
less than four minutes injection to
injection sample prep to recover so many
different drugs can be challenging the
summary on this page is a recent
addition to the sample prep we wanted to
improve our detection of some of the
benzodiazepines that are glue tirana
dated because the gleacher on I don't
recover well with our extraction method
so we added a hydrolysis step riza roof
and glue chirren ID is being used as a
hydrolysis marker in each sample so we
take 200 microliters of our sample
controls and calibrator aliquot them out
we add buffer we add the glue cheer on
I'd the Reserva from glucuronic and beta
glucan on today's and the internal
standards we let it sit for 15 minutes
at room temperature and then we proceed
with our normal extraction and I put
this slide out of order this is courtesy
of Lacey Taylor who developed this
method this was just showing that our
detection of the glitter on today to
benzo
was improved with the hydrolysis so
reasor orphan was included to monitor
and enzymatic hydrolysis activity
biological samples that included the
rapid enzymatic hydrolysis step showed
the presence of resolution analyte as
expected surprisingly resolution analyte
concentrations varied greatly in the
biological samples indicating the
variability of extraction and zoom
addict activity from specimen de
specimen Lacey Taylor is a newer are
addition to our R&D group and she
presented this at soft in Dallas a
couple of weeks ago and actually won the
young forensic scientists award for her
poster and so we're all very proud of
her so on to the rest of the sample prep
after the hydrolysis samples are
transferred onto a bio Taj I salute SOE
plus 96 well plate positive pressure
manifold is used to push the sample into
the packing material it's eluded with
ethyl acetate and dried under nitrogen
at 40 degrees for 10 minutes we use the
bio Taj a CT plate adapter because we
learned that plates were getting
contaminated when there were samples
that had really high levels of things
like methamphetamine or morphine and we
kind of hypothesized that it formed a
cloud and would dissipate over the plate
and contaminate wells around it so this
plate adapter seems to have eliminated
the problem
this is a semi-quantitative a say we
were just calling things positive or
negative not putting a concentration
level on it so it's a one-point
calibration curve at the cutoff and its
forced through zero we're normalizing 27
internal standards we have QC at fifty
percent and one hundred and fifty
percent of the cutoff front and back and
qualitative results are based on the
cutoff mass match retention time and
isotope spacing and abundance
statistical analysis of our calibrator
and control replicates are used to
determine acceptance criteria for the
math match relative retention time and I
on suppression in the internal standard
and last time I checked our fifty
percent control had a median cv of
eleven percent and our one hundred and
fifty percent control that contains all
the analytes had a median cv of nine
point two percent this is an example of
the calibrator flagging calls attention
to things that may be falling outside of
the established criteria you can see the
calibrator with to TC points on either
side in the bottom right hand corner and
then in the bottom left hand corner you
can see the stick chromatogram with
boxes around each of the each mass and
those are the isotope that's for the
isotope ratio and spacing which i
mentioned as part of the data acceptance
criteria so this report looks pretty
complex but really when you're reviewing
it the only things you have to look at
our what is being flagged as outside of
your criteria
just some remarks on this particular
test overall it performs very well but
there's some challenges the laboratory
was confirming approximately twenty
percent of samples by lc-ms ms or twenty
percent of the positive samples by lc-ms
ms typically this was because when
metabolite pattern was abnormal or the
score is suboptimal do would do a high
mass air or a slight shift in retention
time or what we call an isobaric
imitator so it's an uncharacterized
interference and we haven't been able to
figure out what it is but this can push
the turnaround time out a couple of days
and the sample has to be reprinted it
sent to another Department in our
building for for confirmation so
obviously this is an ideal situation
having a well-characterized assay with
tight acceptance criteria and a good
understanding of how things should look
can help prevent these ambiguous results
but you're still going to have issues
from time to time this is an example of
a biological specimen that needed to be
confirmed by lc-ms ms the mass accuracy
was way off for both the alprazolam and
its metabolites alpha-hydroxy alprazolam
as the mass as is the match score if you
look at the isotope pattern it is clear
there's something interfering with the
analyte the specimen came back positive
for both analytes with alprazolam at 26
nanograms per mil and alpha hydroxy
alprazolam at 104 nanograms per mil
since having the specimen confirmed on
another platform and another laboratory
is inefficient we wondered if we could
use our cue tops fragmentation abilities
to confirm the specimens instead it
would be cheaper because it doesn't
require repress by the other lab I use
the same chromatography and went from
there there are a few different ways to
select what you want to fragment on the
agilent q toss i chose to use the auto m
sms setting with a preferred list by
selecting preferred list only the
instrument will only fragment what is on
that list much like a triple quad you
can
also have it fragment analytes from the
preferred list first and then anything
else after it if you're doing unknown
screening if it has time to do it or can
fragment everything that meets us a
criteria that you set so you can set
like an ion or like an abundance
threshold collision energies in this
particular method were set at 20 n 20
and 40 the acquisition rate for the mass
spec was at eight spectra per second and
for m sms is set to four Spectre per
second by making use of the collision
cell we can add a fragmentation pattern
to the other acceptance criteria of mass
accuracy isotope fidelity and retention
time to verify positivity in these
specimens with suboptimal results on the
toss I presented this method it's off to
this in dallas this year this method is
not currently in use however we have a
6550 model of the cute off which is more
of a research grade instrument with an
overprotective research scientist me at
the helm it didn't sit well into the
laboratories workflow so they continued
to confirm what they needed to buy
triple quad but i was able to
demonstrate that should they want to go
down this route they could use this
instrument to confirm instead of the
triple quad this is what the cute off
data looks like in math hunter
qualitative analysis the diamonds across
the peak in the chromatogram rip
chromatogram results plane are where the
instrument has fragmented the in the MS
spectrum results pane at the top the top
box shows the intact I on and the boxes
below show this fragmentation pattern at
each collision energy this pattern is
compared to the fragmentation pattern in
the library and is assigned to match
score in addition to the overall score
that includes mass mashed isotope
fidelity and retention time
this is a comprehensive drug screen
developed on the toss by katherine smith
and was presented at ms ACL earlier this
year it was meant to be a no it's meant
to be an overdose panel so we have
really high cut-offs and long beautiful
well separated chromatography sample
preparation is a dilute and shoot
approach with the dilly went being an
internal standard solution the
separation is achieved on an agilent
poor she'll ECC 18 column and mobile
phases are five millimolar ammonium
formate and optima grade methanol in
positive mode the reference masses which
are infused along with the samples can
be used to evaluate I on suppression
since they are constantly being infused
to correct the mass calibration both
masses are fairly smooth all the way
across the chromatogram indicating that
despite being a dilute and shoot method
there is little to no I on suppression
using the divert valve is critical with
the dilute and shoot prep because all
the junk comes off the column at the
beginning and at the end and so we don't
want to send that in to the mass spec so
that's what the those lines on either
side of the map of the chromatogram are
the one and two and two and three those
are different experiments so experiment
one is being sent to waste an experiment
three is being sent to waste so we're
only collecting between experiment and
experiment 2 this is what negative mode
looks like separation is done on a
shorter c18 column with a bit slower
flow rate than the positive mode method
the aqueous mobile phase is 0.1 percent
acetic acid in water and optimum ethanol
using the acetic acid rather than the
ammonium formate and formic acid mobile
phase used in positive mode boosted our
sensitivity quite a bit
mass hunter qualitative analysis is used
to evaluate the data like in the first
method I discussed a one-point
calibration the cutoff force through the
origin is used two levels of to see on
either side of the calibrator and a
negative controller used to evaluate the
calibration this method is not meant to
produce a quantitative result but rather
a present or not present results
acceptance criteria are very
straightforward if an analyte doesn't
meet them it is considered not present
so I have a confession I am the world's
most impatient chromatography a little
over a year ago I was talking with one
of our medical directors dr. Fred
strassman about other ways in which we
could use that the the top in the in the
laboratory we began to wonder if we
could use the top to replace enzyme
immunoassay the enzyme immunoassay
portion of a screen with reflex approach
to drug screening enzyme immunoassay is
plagued with issues like false positives
and false negatives for example
wellbutrin and pseudoephedrine can cause
an amphetamine immunoassay to be
positive clonazepam and seven amino clin
clonazepam on the other hand have
extremely poor cross-reactivity like
they need to be a thousand anagrams four
mil in concentration and urine to show
positive so they are likely being missed
enzyme immunoassay kits are also
expensive which is another disadvantage
to the technique don't get me wrong
amino acid is a good broad test and it
is robust in the served laboratory as
well for years we just wanted to see if
we could do better so the goals of this
project were to make the screen faster
cheaper and have a higher specificity
than sensitivity than the immunoassay
cut-offs would be analytes this is
specific rather than drug class specific
another advantage to screening by Toph
is we would not need to wait for an
immunoassay kit to be developed for a
new drug that's on the market we could
just get a standard for it and add it to
the assay since any positives would
still be reflex to confirmation in
quantitation by lc-ms ms the
chromatography didn't need to be perfect
but just good enough
sample prep is dilute and shoot this is
76 compounds in positive mode in less
than 90 seconds a short column high
temperature and fast flow rate are used
I don't want to give away too many
details though because I haven't
published this method yet so it this is
just a preview this contains all the
typical drugs of abuse like instant and
set amines cocaine opiates
benzodiazepines and PCP as well as
nicotine and its metabolites and some
tri cyclic to antidepressants this is
negative mode twenty analytes in less
than 90 seconds including SL glue Kieran
I'd NFL sulfate also included or THC
barbiturates and some of the benzo
glucuronic cool right but what about
creatinine we did that too so I've got a
five point calibration curve for
creatinine and four levels of QC and we
are just a few experiments where we just
have a few more experiments to run and
we'll be ready to write the manuscript
and hopefully present this at a
conference soon time of flight is a very
powerful tool when it comes to unknown
screening a biological specimen was
suspected of having some sort of
amphetamine like compound in it the
medical director gave it to me and said
here you go have fun so I love
troubleshooting and solving mysteries so
I happily ran off to the laboratory to
work on the cute off so i deluded this
the specimen in mobile phase at a x 20
dilution and then I analyzed it using
kind of a generic method probably a c18
column I used math hunter qualitative
analysis find by formula and the Agilent
forensic toxicology pc dl and the most
likely hit i came up with was this 25
dimethicone feta mean or do see it had a
score of 98 with math match and isotope
fidelity but i didn't have a retention
time because i didn't have a reference
standard since i didn't have a reference
standard to verify the retention time I
made an auto ms/ms
method on the Qt us knowing that the
fragmentation would give me another
level of certainty when compared in the
fragmentation pattern to the library
there was a match score of 95 so I had a
98 on the the first match scored a 95 on
the library score so do we even need to
order a reference standard it's an
interesting question to think about if
you have an excellent score for math
match isotope fidelity and fragmentation
pattern what are the chances of software
is telling you wrong well I don't know
the answer to that exact question but we
were still quite confident in the data
but I went ahead and ordered the do see
anyway and where we could verify the
retention time and as you can see in
this example the that reference standard
and the the drug in the biological
specimen matched so it's very likely
that this specimen did contain the do
see top as a powerful tools a lot of
applications you can do targeted
screening you can do untargeted
screening it's very user-friendly method
development is generally easy and new
compounds can be added quickly but
assays need to be well characterized you
need to make sure that you have strict
acceptance criteria and have tried to
account for any possible isobaric
interferences that are not part of your
assay if anyone is interested any of the
presented published methods I talked
about talked about I can get the posters
to you I would like to thank our UT
laboratories dr. Fred strassman
catherine smith lacy taylor the ARU p
institute for clinical and experimental
pathology and the clinical toxicology
three laboratory i would like to also
thank Angelyn technologies specifically
Carrie Adler one of my former a RUP
colleagues John Palmer and Julie cat
Shelly are
excellent resources when it comes to
chromatographic separation and cute off
help and then I would also like to thank
lab roots for giving the opportunity to
talk to you guys today and with that I
would like to open it up for questions
it's time for Q&A Thank You Natalie for
that informative presentation it's time
for Q&A if you have a question you'd
like to ask Natalie please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click
the send button we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
let's get started Natalie our first
question is how is the match score
calculated it's an algorithm in the
software it takes into account mass
accuracy retention time match and
isotope fidelity so isotope ratio and
spacing and then that can also be
changed the waiting can be changed
depending on the type of analysis you're
doing so if it's a SAS chromatography
you can decrease for example the
weighting of the isotope fidelity and
increase the weighting of the other two
parameters now what sort of experience
does a tech need to competently run the
instrument and analyze the data I
started running this instrument as a med
tech on the bench and having a little
bit of a mass spectrometry background
helped it's certainly something that you
know a bachelor's level like medical
technologist can run and and understand
it's not extraordinarily difficult to
learn how to analyze the data you just
have to know what good data looks like
and have that well defined very good now
let's see here's another question um
Nellie when conducting your general
unknown screen with the masterpiece edl
did you encounter erroneous results by
using only accurate mass if so how did
you determine what is real versus
erroneous um I didn't have any erroneous
results but that concern I think as far
as erroneous results if you had like a
bunch of matches for a bunch of isobaric
compounds you would have to either
fragment using the cute off or order
standards and match to retention time so
yeah I I guess that's probably how I
would approach it very good um let's say
let's give them audience just a moment
to see if we have any more questions
coming in it looks like
as we're waiting for any questions
Natalie if you want to give us any final
comments for the audience anything you'd
like to add nothing comes to mind right
now I think I covered almost everything
I wanted to but I'm always happy like if
anybody asked thinks of a question that
they want to ask after this there they
can always send me an email or you guys
can probably tell them how to get in
contact with me and I'm always happy to
answer stuff offline as well yes
absolutely because on today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
all the way through februari 2017 and
during those during that a demand
viewing you can submit questions and now
they will be happy to respond to you
offline and you will be receiving an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay and we do ask that you share your
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event let's
see I believe we have time for another
question um Nelly with such short run
times did you have a post time to help
equal liberate before the next injection
yeah my post time let's see I think the
post time on the first examples with the
35 drugs is around 1 minute it's 30
seconds in the rapid screen and then i'm
not sure what the post time is on the
longer comprehensive method very good
see I believe those are all the
questions that we have again you're
welcome to submit during the on demand
and now they will respond offline and
again it's available through on-demand
viewing through februari 2017 and again
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available thank you for joining us I
believe that's all for now we hope to
see you again soon goodbye